did you know that Darth Vader you both
step toward
is running for president the ukraine
don't take my word for it we've got
video poker the
the
I
here okay
Peter yeah
I okay well you've got my vote
yeah I'm not alright so this is actually
only partially a joke
I hadn't to Darth Vader this guide did
run
in 2012 he was not on the ballot but he
got three percent the writings which is
completely insane
they threw that out because they don't
even count the writing but he did get
three percent that's a pretty decent
percentage
perset Lord water summit his political
actions with my dad in 2013
he was carried in a sedan chair by a
group with Imperial Stormtroopers to
Odessa
City Hall declaring himself acting mayor
of the city citing an order by Amber
albertine and I they said he scored a
record three percent vote in 2012
parliamentary election and both were
never registered because they were
write-ins which rendered them boy under
Ukrainian law
what he actually this actually is
becoming something he's running
on the Ukrainian internet party
and a ok and your best
to run you have to get you to read 200
and 36 thousand dollars the party has
already done that for him so yes this is
obviously a joke
and we can be joking about it but he's
actually doing this to
so it just sorta what we needed to like
get a little sense that ukraine thinkers
everybody's talking about here nobody
sure what's going on ken starr words
give us a little
momentary how ya this is the greatest
thing that ever happen to politics
I mean I wanna like you know raise some
money and then
you know your big golden girls fam well
you know
the try to run for election as our
favorite golden girl hanging in there so
I me a Burberry way home I gotta tell a
secretarial and a group for all of them
a yeah you know I think it's its a it's
actually it's so absurd
I mean putting is so absurd the whole
situation so absurd so why not have
Darth Vader
if the mythical James Earl Jones
controls voice like that really really
I mean the guy's voice message was
pretty good miss Ukraine in a rush in
with the other day when I was like well
what is it was the Ukrainian
I think it was my own little way off but
no and no do you think Putin
actually NB this guy low-key put a
shorter would like to rule like Darth
Vader
wooden important is a badass he just
crashes people
row I think that he probably saw this in
is like you would destroy that the way
the record you know I
the eighth even more evil yeah was
actually made me feel like the guy
me like the it will be interesting if
the governor Mark Hamill look alike as
it looks scott Walker's right then
there's like the good
hi could be kinda fun people are drawn
to the darkside all right if you were
gonna vote for one or the other you'd
probably vote dark side
with their old are the mean the the
whole bush administration access to
evoke a I was always all yours out the
Star Wars II I honestly think that's how
did
explain that the george bush that light
I'm says I honestly think that there are
this Alyssa Thomas is like Darth Vader
no are
yeah they're
its bill yeah he will hand deliver yeah
you know it I well in revenge in the set
you know there was the big line the push
that about you either with us or against
us and religious it which came out after
that
they said it I mean attic anti-worker
says it to obi-wan Kenobi and you're
either with me or your
or your enemies balls with you know
you'd like are you the one who their
puppet government RR
to know that things yeah it just know is
Darth Vader is this like a third party
origins the it's the Ukrainian internet
in our day but I mean they're actually
raising the way do we need a little this
on our power
our political system it's such a mess
here do we need some like
joke like either comedian to run or
something crazy like that have nearly
ended in the
me that I think well we had a what is a
minute without Al Franken a Minnesota
are you pay pass away now Gary Coleman
ranking for something
de niro I over yeah it's all quite a
bore
if we talk about okay never take care
with
that was this whole thing ok but we
don't talk about 2.1 per
that do we need like something like that
ish a cover system it's so broke in
right
do everything to be because like the
situation in Ukraine is so tenuous and
its
so a it's really like we haven't seen if
typeof like aggression
in into what and a long time you know
within the aggression between like you
know
you know nora is both the North and
South Dakota North
yeah and fed a lot going on there
let another big boat and let their
people leaving yeah
I like it at my eyes when he said i like
yur from North Dakota I know you know
anything to
ok but you know you know a country like
taking over just flat out like I'm gonna
take this riot in a very careful we're
gonna but you know
our guards on your border in Feb so its
own serious in it so I call my god
what's going to happen day today that
its a
a little bit surprising to me that there
is a duck it's better like oh and hey
both and we gotta
you know and we also have Darth Vader a
regular credit by email
you're going to have a great day I think
that rate I think Darth Vader should be
in every election
yeah and yeah I really do think that
doctor doctor should read it
every country here everyone can be over
there
yeah I'm the amazing you know how many
people honest to god you know how many
Americans
would raise money and would bow they
what
they would only they're so sick a both
parties yeah
there so I was if you if you had maybe
like not a Darth Vader but you if you
had like an American folk hero
right like a are no like somewhat like a
look at what
standard made in america prepares like
that okayed Nugent
no not aggressive Iran for eighth-grade
representative in junior high school
and I was the only one running there's
no so I had the way I had the way
yeah i win yeah and I got all the voters
that one person that a ride and they
road and Donald Duck so I think I've
Donald Duck brand adult that somebody
like that from an unlikely to ever be a
good
I'm telling you they would raise a lot
of money and they would get really far
because people are so sick
what's happening in like congress that
there so take a bold parties like if
someone
a yeah I got grant yeah I believe the
final thought on this
we think George Lucas things when he
sees this stuff like he just had this
idea
around 1974 this little space idea and
it became this thing that is
so beyond barker's huge culturally and
politically
you be watching this companies like this
is some crazy shit
upgrade I mean of course k think I mean
they can know if
if you ever have I you know you do TV
show or you do it
stand up thing area on the shore Smith
three runs up ten does estar UN
you know thank you very much either I
mean can you imagine if
level that this guy has his character's
run a run for the
I mean it's crazy yeah right created a
character they wanted to rule the
universe and now the other guy actually
running
yeah 100 Superman Superman could run
for president I'd States people loves
government
when I think I I think anyone I mean
that's what if you did it like American
Idol -style
yeah you can end up with the wrong
people if they like is that if you get
the right way of getting the wrong
people anyway yeah
many Christina Aguilera could be running
the country because out to be like yeah
phone well we need a lady maker
are about her but Christina Aguilera 26
be there you go
good God
up